from being freed from the matrix as a
child to saving humanity from extinction
morpheus has quite the life story do you
think you know it all let's review like
the man himself all we're offering is
the truth and nothing more
like many people freed from the virtual
reality prison of the matrix morpheus is
awakened into reality as a child and
spends his adolescence in the last human
city of zion he grows up preparing
himself to do battle against the
machines eventually joining the
resistance and becoming the captain of
his own hovercraft the nebuchadnezzar
within the matrix morpheus becomes a
formidable warrior and hacker infamous
even among humans who are still plugged
in and unaware that their world is an
illusion he is considered by
many authorities to be the most
dangerous man alive
eventually he visits the oracle an
allegedly prescient spiritual leader
according to her prophecy his destiny is
to find the one a person born in the
matrix who has the ability to manipulate
its simulated reality at will and is
destined to lead the humans to freedom
upon learning this morpheus surrounds
himself with a crew who are all equally
devoted to his cause and sets out to
fulfill his destiny
in the matrix morpheus finally tracks
down the person he believes to be the
one a hacker called neo who is obsessed
with the strange feeling that his world
is not what it seems morpheus sends
trinity one of his most loyal crew
members to monitor neo and eventually
makes contact when they finally meet
face to face morpheus offers neo a
choice represented by two pills if neil
takes the blue pill he'll return to his
own life and never hear from morpheus
again if neo takes the red pill morpheus
will show him the truth about the world
but there will be no going back luckily
neo takes the red pill and morpheus and
his crew are able to disconnect him from
the matrix awakening him to the harsh
reality of the real world morpheus soon
introduces neo to the prophecy of the
one and begins training neil to fulfill
his destiny neo has a hard time
believing that he's somehow the savior
of humanity but morpheus faith is
unshakable i don't believe it
it's not possible
i didn't say it would be easy neo
i just said it would be the truth he
attempts to shake neo of his
preconceptions about what is possible
showing him that within the simulation
of the matrix one can exert their will
to bend or break the laws of physics to
become an unstoppable warrior neo needs
only to believe in himself as much as
morpheus believes in him and he can be
strong enough to defeat the machines
during a mission in the matrix the crew
of the nebuchadnezzar is betrayed to the
machines and cornered by their agent
enforcers to ensure that his crew can
get neo to safety morpheus throws
himself at the agents since no human has
ever survived a fight with an agent
morpheus does this with every
expectation that this sacrifice will
mean his death the great morpheus
we meet upon us
and you are
a smith
agent smith
instead he's captured and brought to a
government stronghold for interrogation
as a captain in the resistance fleet
morpheus possesses the security codes
for zion's defense mainframe the
machines know they'll never be able to
coerce this information out of morpheus
by conventional means so they inject his
avatar in the matrix with a computer
virus intended to break his will
morpheus fights their influence for
hours expecting that his crew will make
the practical choice to unplug his body
from the matrix killing him before the
virus can force him to talk neo and
trinity however are unwilling to
sacrifice morpheus and hack back into
the matrix to save him their daring
rescue attempt is a success and with
their help he's able to regain his
strength of will and rid his mind of the
agent's influence neo also finds his
faith in himself during the mission and
accepts his destiny as the one
validating morpheus faith in him
the matrix reloaded picks up six months
after morpheus rescue and neos ascension
to digital demigod as neo's power in the
matrix grows so does morpheus's
reputation among the people of zion more
and more of them put their faith in the
idea that neo will defeat the machines
and end the war this is a source of
frustration for jason locke commander of
zion's defense forces who is not a
believer and wants zion to focus their
efforts on bolstering the city's
defenses as if that wasn't enough locke
is also niobe's live-in partner and is
clearly jealous of her former
relationship with morpheus
what is it between them morpheus and log
niobee captain ivy
she used to be with morpheus
now she's with locke
this conflict comes to a head when it's
discovered that a massive army of
machine sentinels is drilling towards
zion from the surface zion will need to
rally every ship and every soldier to
have even a chance of repelling the
invasion but morpheus convinces zion's
ruling council to allow him and a few
other ships to leave the city and
broadcast into the matrix so that neo
can continue his prophesied path to
victory if locke were thinking
objectively he'd realize that even the
full strength of zion's military doesn't
stand a chance against the machines and
that morpheus gamble far-fetched as it
is might be their only chance locke
however is too stubborn and too wounded
by the subversion of his authority to
see it that way he fights morpheus at
every turn but morpheus wins not only
the faith of the council but also the
vocal support of the people of zion
neo meets with the oracle and returns
with a mission that he's been told will
bring the path of the one to an end
what happens if i fail
then zion
will fall
neo and company will need to break a
program called the key maker from a
well-guarded dungeon sneak him and neo
into a particular building and disable
the power grid of mega city to disable
its explosive security countermeasures
this mission will require the
cooperation of three separate hovercraft
crews and morpheus convinces captain
niobe of the logos and captain soren of
the vigilant to lend their support
together they successfully shepherd neo
and the key maker to their destination
fighting off both agents and the key
makers wardens along the way neo's
mission however turns out to be another
trick put in place by the machines the
oracle's prophecy is actually a
complicated ruse through which the
machines have been manipulating the
resistance the war continues with no
clear path forward even hearing about
this twist straight from neo's mouth
morpheus faith still can't be fully
broken the one was never meant to end
anything
it was all another system of control
i don't believe that
he soon bears another blow to his
resolve when his beloved hovercraft
nebuchadnezzar is destroyed by sentinels
the crew survives but the future of the
resistance is left uncertain as the
machine army grows ever closer to zion
the matrix revolutions picks up
immediately after the destruction of the
nebuchadnezzar as morpheus and his crew
are picked up by another resistance
hovercraft the hammer they're joined
shortly thereafter by the logos
commanded by morpheus's ex captain naobi
the three crews decide that their best
course of action is to return to zion to
help them defend against the machine
invasion meanwhile neo has learned that
he still has a chance of ending the war
if he can make his way to the machine's
capital city in person i can only hope
you know what you're doing
me too
niobi volunteers to pilot the hammer
through a dangerous shortcut back home
to zion and offer neo and trinity the
use of the logos for their trip to the
machine city niobe may never have
believed in the prophecy of the one but
she does believe in neo morpheus acts as
niobe's copilot for the rest of the
mission as she navigates the hammer
through a narrow passageway to zion the
experience draws them closer together
and is strongly implied that they'll be
resuming their relationship after the
end of the war you're a hell of a pilot
some things in this world never change
when the hammer reaches zion its emp
weapon buys the resistance a few
precious hours before the machines can
regroup and resume their invasion during
his debriefing with the council morpheus
reasserts his faith in neo even though
he's not sure exactly how he will be
able to save them but i do know that
as long as there is a single breath in
his body
he will not give up
the sentinels once again breach the city
but suddenly halt their advance the rest
of zion's forces are puzzled but
morpheus knows that this is neo's doing
hundreds of miles away neo has
negotiated a cease-fire with the
machines a former agent called smith has
transformed into a nigh unstoppable
computer virus that threatens to consume
not only the matrix but the entire
machine civilization only neo stands a
chance against him in battle so neo
offers to plug back into the matrix and
confront him in exchange for an end to
the war neo succeeds at the cost of his
own life and the sentinels retreat from
zion morpheus is the first to understand
what's happened his faith and a lifetime
of struggle rewarded morpheus embraces
naobi and sheds tears of joy and relief
morpheus is the only main character from
the original matrix film to survive the
entire trilogy and his story has been
continued both in the series original
continuation the matrix online and in
the much later film sequel the matrix
resurrections the matrix online was a
massive multiplayer rpg that operated
between 2005 and 2009 and dealt with the
machine wars aftermath one of the game's
early story lines reveals that the
machines have not returned neo's body to
zion morpheus is enraged by this and
sets out on a deadly campaign to
destabilize the matrix until his
friend's body is released soon after
morpheus is assassinated by a program
presumably working for the sinister
merovingian but the mystery is never
fully resolved it's unknown as of this
video whether or not any story elements
from the matrix online will be honored
in future stories morpheus will also
reappear in the matrix resurrections now
played by yaya abdul mateen ii in place
of original actor lawrence fishburn
though abdul mateen has implied that his
character may not be exactly the morphy
as we remember for answers we'll just
have to wait until morpheus offers up
the red pill once again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]